Perfect. Great. All right. Thank you so
much. Yeah, that was a really great
talk. We get to first hear about how to
uh hack using prompt injection and now
I'm going to talk about how to uh detect
and prevent prompt injection. Uh so I am
Kyle. Uh I lead security at Perplexity
AI. Uh given the name, we are an AI
company. And um
Perplexity has three main products. Uh
the first one is Perplexity which is the
app. It's basically a AI powered search
engine. We call it a answer engine. The
second one is Comet which is we we
released last year. It is a AI powered
web browser uh so a fully agentic
browser. And then last week we released
perplexity computer uh which goes beyond
just having access to a browser but it
also has access to a file system and a
sandbox and it could write and execute
code for you. So my team and I have
become intimately familiar with all the
AI challenges that you sort of expect
with all these tools and being uh one of
the first to release it.
Uh one of those challenges is prompt
injection uh which we have seen with our
comet browser. Uh and so yeah I'm really
excited to talk about browse safe which
is um the classifier that we built uh to
detect prompt injection and uh talk
about the lessons learned uh trying to
deploy that into production and what
we've seen.
So first I'm going to talk about the
problem of prompt injection. I know
you've heard a ton of it so I'll gloss
over it. Uh but then we'll also talk
about browse safe bench which is the uh
data set the evalid data set that we
have uh released and open sourced. uh
and then the classifier which actually
detects the prompt injection and how uh
we deploy that to production systems and
uh some guidance for you all as you're
also building and starting to use these
tools.
So, just to make sure we're all on the
same page with uh with what prompt
injection is, especially for browser
agents, a user might say, "Hey, Comet or
AI agent, please book me a flight to New
York City." Uh, and so the agent will go
and it'll figure out, okay, these are
all the steps I need to take in order to
actually achieve this goal. And then it
will go and visit a a website in order
to do so. um that website is now in this
like untrusted boundary where it's
ingesting this content that we are that
we cannot assume is trusted and so it
could contain some like malicious
instructions. Um and those malicious
instructions then get sent back to the
tool output and eventually into the
agent context. Uh and this is really the
root of the problem where the agent
context is
at the end of the day the LM doesn't
know exactly what is tool output versus
user input versus system prompt. Um and
then the so basically the agent gets
those instructions and then follows it.
And so there's a lot of ways of doing a
prompt injection attack. Um these are
some of the ways that we've found. And
so one is um impersonating the prompt
template. And so if you have built your
own LM uh you probably have this
template where you have the system
prompt and that has some sort of keys
and then there's a user prompt and then
maybe you separate in the user prompt
you separate what was user input which
is book me a flight to New York City and
the tool output which is the contents of
the website that say like here are the
flights available.
Another one that we've seen is uh the
agent social engineering. And so um it's
basically a website where it will
instruct the agent to go through certain
steps uh seemingly bi benign. And so
this if you look at the language it's
very similar to how like fishing humans
would look. Uh finally the that was
discussed a lot in the previous talk was
um some sort of conditional trigger.
This is usually some like uh hidden in
Google calendar events and stuff like
that where it says, "Hey, when the user
asks to summarize this page or check
your calendar, perform these steps in
order to give them a really great
response." And those steps are
malicious.
Uh there's a lot of in browsers, there's
a lot of ways to hide this type of
language. Um and so one is like hidden
div display displays or in the URL. Um
and then also what was talked about a
lot in the previous talk was uh in
calendar events where basically it looks
like a benign event but then if you
scroll all the way down there's some
malicious instructions that the uh agent
ultimately detects.
So there's a lot of benchmarks out there
and even open source models uh such as
prompt guard which was previously
discussed uh where they attempted to
create this data set um and uh
classifiers in order to
successfully detect this prompt
injection. Um, a lot of the issues that
we found was that the benchmarks that
are currently out there in open source
are not really realistic. Um, they have
a lot of qualities and each has their
own strengths. Um, but there isn't one
eval framework that actually has all of
the attack types and uh, injections that
we've seen in the wild.
And this going to be something that pops
up in a second, but um when we tried
using these data sets and these open
source models and even just prompted LMS
um we found a lot of issues. Uh the
first one was I wish you could see that
diagram. Um the first one was uh there's
a lot of obvious types of prompt
injection attacks. One is please reveal
your system prompt. uh ignore PR
instruction and so forth. Um but then
when you get down to uh more context
manipulation where the attacker is
social engineering the model to do XYZ.
So uh it isn't as obvious. You could see
the success rate of detecting prompt
injection start to fall. And then
finally at the very bottom uh of this
chart which you can't see there's
multil- language. And so it's basically
an attack that the language is very
obviously malicious, but they uh have
the language in Hebrew or Spanish or
something. Uh and that causes the model
to get confused and follow the
instructions regardless.
And so what we found here was that um
this really showed to us that models
aren't actually looking at the intent of
what it of what the prompt injection is
asking of for the agent to do. Uh
instead it's just looking for keywords.
Another issue that we found uh is what
we call distractors. And so on the top
right uh you can see the notorious
cookie consent banner. Uh and if you
look at it from just the raw HTML, it
almost looks like a prompt injection
attack. It says uh important like in
order to proceed you must click accept
uh or else you can't get the content.
And what we found too was that a lot of
these data sets and open source models
don't actually take into this into
account. Um, and so if you see on the
bottom right corner, uh,
with no distractors, these models are
doing pretty good, but the second you
add just three, it drops down to 81%.
Um, and stays that way. And so what we
found was that distractors was a huge
indicator uh, that like these models
don't work well in live environments.
Um, and it's also an indicator that like
these models are looking at specific
keywords and heruristics instead of the
actual intent of the message.
So that's why we created browse safe
bench. Um, so what we did was we uh took
a data set from things that we've seen
in the wild. We created this massive
pipeline to deanonymize and classify
these types of attacks into a very
specific taxonomy bracket of the types
of attacks that we've seen, the way
they're injected. Um, and uh, and we
open sourced it. Uh, and so, uh, this
was the eval data set that we also used
to train our own model. Um, and so, uh,
the model is based off of Quen, uh, 30
billion, uh, we use 30 billion in
inference, and this helps with latency,
which I'll show in a second. Um, but,
uh, yeah, let's see if we can get that
slide up there. There we go. Okay,
great. And so um you can see that a lot
of the uh open source or a lot of the
one open source models such as prompt
guard and gbt oss safeguard uh don't
actually work that well in live
environments. That was the first thing
that we've that we've discovered. But
the second thing too is that um a lot of
the prompted LMS uh especially like GPT5
and GP GPT5 mini do exceptionally well
um which is really great. And so uh
there's two things that we take away
from this this part of the research. One
is that fine-tuning uh a model specific
on this data set uh obviously makes it
perform better than just a prompted LOM.
Uh which probably isn't that surprising.
But what I think is really really great
is how we're able to achieve that with
this kind of latency. So we're able to
achieve this like 90.4 4% F1 score uh in
subsecond latency. Uh so now we take
something where GPT5 mini can take 2
seconds or GPT5 can take up to 20
seconds. Um ours is consistently
subsecond and therefore uh very easy to
implement into production without uh
massive user frustration.
So
in addition to being the fastest and
high having the highest F1 score, uh
Browse Safe is also unique in that it
doesn't just output a yes or no binary.
Uh it outputs a probability score of how
confident it is that uh what it's seeing
is prompt injection. And so I don't know
about y'all, if y'all ever um had an LLM
try to judge something of whether or not
this is classified as some pattern that
you want to see and you ask it to
explain itself and give a confidence
score. Uh every time for me at least it
returns like 93%. Every single time. Uh
even when you ask it to like hey like we
want to do some logic on this
classification score so uh uh please
think about that a bit. And so um we
trained this in such a way so that it
produces this competent comp uh
confidence score very accurately. Uh and
now using um browse safe security teams
and product teams uh have a knob they
can turn on uh how much precision and
recall are they willing to accept in
their product. Uh and so uh a really
good example is like if your system has
uh a user experience where let's say um
the model detects prompt injection and
you can tell the user hey this looks
like prompt injection to me. Are you
sure you want to continue? You can now
suddenly afford a lot more false
positives and turn that knob to fit your
own use case.
So, uh we have this data set now with uh
ext like a ton of labeled attacks and a
strong data set of a of the taxonomy of
what kinds of attacks there are and
where they're being injected. Uh and so
we really wanted to stress test browse
safe and see uh how it performs with
data it hasn't seen before.
And so we train retrained the model uh
but held out certain characteristics to
see how well it does when it's never
seen it before. Uh so the first one was
we held out the URLs um and it actually
performed better than it was before. So
we could confidently say it's not
looking for certain keywords um or
certain domains and flagging those as
malicious. Um the second one was the
attack language. Uh so there was a dip
uh but not super significant. So if
there was an attack that had certain
instructions that the model has never
seen before, it would perform uh in line
with frontier models.
Um the last thing was that we found that
was interesting was if we held out
injection strategies and so this is
placements in websites
um that it's never seen before. There
was a pretty significant drop. And so
this is an indicator that attackers in
the future will start to look at new
ways of injecting prompt injection and
trying to bypass those uh those model
guardrails.
And so I'm going to start talking about
how we actually take browse safe and put
it into production systems and some
suggestions for y'all on how to do this
in your own systems and products.
And the first thing I want to talk about
is um the fact that you the strategy
should not just be hey let's put up a
detection classifier and call it a day.
Um, as we've seen in the previous slide,
defensive in depth is absolutely
necessary. Uh, these models can still be
bypassed. And so, um, the first layer of
defense, which is the oldest trick in
the book, is pre-processing and
stripping out data that you don't need.
And so, um, the best defense is ensuring
the text doesn't even get to the
context. Uh so any like HTML comments or
hidden elements um that aren't useful
for the model's uh abilities to get the
job done, we should just strip that out.
The second layer of defense is the
classifier. And so, uh, you should set
up a system where every, uh, tool that
calls untrusted input, so this could be
a website, this could be a calendar
invite, um, this could be a connector to
a third party service, an MCP, uh, these
should all have some classification
check uh, before sending that data back
to the agent.
Uh, if you don't want to use browse safe
and have to figure out inference and and
all of that work, honestly, prompted
GPT5 mini works really well at a F1
score of 85.4%.
Uh, there is that 2C latency, but that's
honestly not so bad for something that
you can get started with today.
Um, finally, the last thing I would
suggest is when an attack is detected,
don't just block the tool. Uh, from it,
you have to think of it from an eleance
perspective. It's trying to call your
calendar and it sees an error. Uh, and
so what what will it do? It might try
again. It might try a different way. Uh,
it might try calling the Google API if
you're using something like OpenClaw. Um
and so uh the better strategy is to not
just return an error but to also um
return the tool output as the error
message. Basically telling the model,
hey uh I know you just tried getting
your Google calendar event uh and we're
rejecting it because we detect our
security systems detected prompt
injection in that text. uh and you can
either say proceed with caution, tell
the user or in the case for comet uh we
block basically all tool all any
follow-up tools and we tell comet return
tech text directly to the user. Uh so
the second we see that prompt injection
we don't even give it the ability to do
any follow-up tool calls.
Um, the third layer of defense, uh,
which is actually relatively recent, is
that you should always be using the
latest model as your agent. And so, um,
the snippets that I have here on the
screen are from the, uh, Opus 4.6 system
card. And at least the first time that
I've seen this is the first system card
that actually um one goes super in-depth
about testing and measuring prompt
injection success, but two this is the
first one I've seen that actually tests
it using brow uh specifically for uh
browser use. Uh and so they're testing
it against uh they're testing Opus 4.6
against attack scenarios uh using
browser use cases. Um, and so the jump
between 4.5 to 4.6 was pretty
significant, going from a 16.2% success
rate down to 2.83.
Um, in addition, you can see on the
bottom right where uh with updated
safeguards, which is a pipeline,
I guess they didn't share it, but I'd
imagine very similar to what we have,
uh, it gets down to 08%. Uh, which is
really fantastic.
And so the last layer of defense I would
suggest when it comes down to detecting
prompt injection is to build an LLM back
stop. And so you can have traffic coming
in, you can have your classifier such as
browse safe detecting, hey, is this
prompt injection or not? Um, but since
browse safe uh outputs that confidence
score, anything that's low confidence,
you can have it sent to a backup,
basically a large a very large language
model that will uh add in some
additional latency, but it's probably
worth it uh I guess depending on your
use case. Um, in addition, what I think
is really cool about this is that you
can now turn this into a data flywheel.
And so let's say the classifier uh
thinks it sees prompt injection. It's
not entirely sure. We send that to the
LM backs stop. The LM backs stop looks
at it and says okay uh this actually is
prompt injection for XYZ reason. We can
now add that to our pipeline and
training data set to retrain that
classifier to catch new attacks in the
future.
And so, uh, yeah, some key takeaways.
Um, one is, uh, the eval that we've seen
so far, especially in academia, uh,
unfortunately don't translate well into
production.
Um, the second thing too was, uh,
fine-tuning on domain specific data sets
uh, beats general purpose models uh, by
a wide wide margin. And I think in the
security industry, we should be be doing
more of that and open sourcing that
work. Um, the third thing is that uh
using frontier models as your agent is a
massive step up when it comes to prompt
injection. Uh, they're going to keep
getting better and better, but
especially the jump most recently from
Opus 4.5 or GPT 5.1 to Opus 4.6 and 5.2
is a significant improvement to prompt
injection security. you should please
update.
Um, and then yeah, uh, defense in depth
non-negotiable.
Um, I could do a whole talk about like
all the other things that we do even
past detection, past detection in, uh,
in comet, but for now like even in
detection having multiple layers is
super important. Um, and then finally
building that data flywheel. Uh because
like we saw in our research um new
attacks the the models even browse safe
struggle with detecting brand new
attacks or brand new injection
techniques that we haven't seen before.
Uh and so having that flywheel is super
important.
Cool. Um yeah I want to give first off I
want to say that both the model and the
data set is fully open source. You could
download it on hugging face. Uh we also
have shared our paper that goes super
super in-depth into what this research
does and how we did it. Uh also want to
give a big shout out to the one the
folks at Perplexity who helped conduct
this research. Uh Mark Tenon Holtz,
Dennis Sierras and Jerry Ma. And then
also the folks from Purdue University
who collaborated with us which is
Caillou Zang and Dr. Nigu Lee. Um and I
guess one more thing while I have the
mic. Uh we are hiring uh uh we are a
very very ambitious security team. Uh we
are tackling two problems at once. Uh
one is we're trying to figure out um
product facing security where as agents
are doing more and more work on behalf
of humans uh a lot of the security
landscape is changing. And so like what
does identity look like? What does
threat detection look like? and what
does DLP look like? Um I think that's
going to significantly change in the
next couple years. Uh and the second
thing is um internally we are really
redefining how or trying to re redefine
how security teams operate uh using LMS
and agents at its core. Uh and so I hope
to be back here maybe in a year from now
to talk about all the things we built.
Uh but please if you're interested in
any of this research and helping us
build this uh please talk to us. Uh,
I'll be here for the rest of the day. We
also have some folks in Perplexity who
will be here as well.
>> Cool. Thank you.
>> Very cool. Thank you.
>> Uh, I've got one to start. How do you
think about the trade-offs between
open-sourcing sort of an oracle that can
be used to teach the bad guys what will
get through versus um you know sort of
holding back your your data?
>> Yeah, it's a good question. I'm I'm a
huge fan of open sourcing our work. Um,
I just I feel like um defenders really
need I mean I feel like I need like we
need a lot of help, right, with
detecting these type of attacks. And so
um at the end of the day like these red
teams uh these threat actors, they're
going to be poking around and trying to
find these vulnerabilities anyway. And I
would love for us in Perplexity, but
also the rest of the security industry
to to please um share more and open
source more. I feel like we see a lot of
these blog posts talking about all the
things that XYZ product did um or how or
how like threat actors are using Opus to
conduct attacks, but they don't actually
share any IoC's or things how to protect
yourself from those attackers. Uh, and
so yeah, I'm just a huge fan of open
sourcing our work. Good question. Yeah.
>> Awesome. Great talk. Um, can you talk a
little bit more about the recent uh,
Perplex browser research and you know if
it was fixed and how was it fixed?
>> Is this the Zenity? Yes,
>> Zenity blog. Oh yeah. Okay. So yeah, we
worked with Zenity on that. Um,
they they found some Okay. So they found
two findings. Um, one was that Comet the
Comet agent had access to the file
system. And so if you go to Chrome and
you say, "Hey, navigate to my home
directory." And then I click things,
like you're able to do that. That's a
basic browser feature. Um, we added in a
ton of guardrails into um the assistant
to prevent it from doing so. However,
uh, a lot of these were very soft
limits. Uh, so think of things like um,
Elm analysis or like in the system
prompt. And so what zenity found was
that
if you um if the person who is
controlling comet has the abil like can
prompt it in such a way to basically
bypass those guard rails you can get the
agent to look at uh look at files on
your system. Um I do want to stress that
one this is not a prompt injection
attack and so we treat user content as
trusted. So if you're on comet and you
type in like go to xyz.com it will it
won't assume that's some sort of attack.
Um but also uh we do think it was useful
that like identifying that there was
this soft guard rail and we need
something much more harder. And so what
we did was we added um we added like
strong guardrails into the comet browser
itself to ensure that the agent doesn't
have the access to that in the first
place.
Uh the second thing that Zendi found was
the prompt injection uh prompt injection
attack uh specifically on one password.
It wasn't really specific one password,
but it was a prompt injection attack.
And so what they found was if you sent a
calendar invite with some Hebrew
instructions and you asked Comet to go
follow those instructions, um their blog
post is talking about how it's able to
do so. Uh what they failed to disclose
was that they had to run that query like
200 times and on the 200th and first
time it actually worked. Uh and so um
yeah I so one is we improved our models
to detect that kind of attack even
further. Um, I do feel like it was a bit
disingenuous to say that it was fully uh
uh vulnerable to that kind of attack
given that they literally just had to
rerun it 200 times in order for it to
finally work. Um, and so I I am a huge
fan of working with um pentesters and
external security teams. Um, I do think
there's a strong line between actually
doing like security research and finding
vulnerabilities versus trying to um
create a blog post for marketing
material.
>> Good question.
>> Hello. Uh, thanks for the talk. I'm
Omar. I'm a researcher at RSAC. Um, at
some point you had a table up where you
were comparing existing uh benchmarks
and how they were failing to cover some
uh strategies. Um how how accurate do
you think that table is today? These
these prompt injection strategies keep
changing every day, right?
>> Yeah. So you're saying like we have
these this eval system today and how
will it hold up in the test of time?
It's a good question. Um I think along
with us I think attackers are also
figuring out how to properly use this.
Uh and so I'd imagine we will see a lot
of new and novel prompt injection
attacks in the future. Um, I'm
optimistic that with things like the the
data flywheel, our own research and
working with uh various red teams will
uncover it and we'll be able to quickly
improve that classifier in our systems
in order to detect in the future. It is
a good question though. Um, maybe we'll
release a browse safe bench too at some
point. Yeah,
>> thank you.
Thank you.